let me ask you about that fight with
Derek you're trying to talk your way out
of this yes what did I say that's false
name one thing that I just mentioned
that's false
Derek any regrets on that it looked like
you weren't really yourself you came a
little bit unhinged honestly that was
not the jpg we knew I didn't say
anything that was false everything I
said was true and that little clip they
showed you know it's a little
unfortunate because I don't actually
have like a video I can show the
conversation but it's unfortunate you
know was word of mouth being inclusive
and being you know very laid back it's
part of my personal culture I think a
lot of people would agree with that and
I try to avoid drama and any unnecessary
confrontation and it's just unfortunate
that tasia had to get you know it was
she was sort of central to the whole
thing well you did not want to offer an
apology to Kris and crystal for getting
into that fight at their wedding why not
I hadn't really thought about it it's
unfortunate to happen at their wedding
but I think just because it's paradise I
think something would would have
unfolded you know regardless so drama I
think I think they knew that sorry
Kristen crystal if I ruined your special
that I didn't mean anything but I want
to ask you about kind of the things you
said that Derek said I know that editing
does happen what did Derek say that made
you look at him differently as a person
I'm out of respect for him I'd rather
not talk about it do you think Derek's a
frat boy who hooks up with fans or do
you think he's a good guy these days I'm
like Derek's a bad guy at all you know
it's just unfortunate that you know my
love interest was involved and you know
I had her best interest in mind and so I
had to had to stick up for her anything
you would have done differently in
Paradise yeah you know what I will say
that probably would have been a little
more wintry yelled but yeah it's just a
really emotionally draining process and
I think I could have turned the the
intensity down a little bit JP Jay will
you ever go on reality TV again because
no absolutely not this is the last stint
I will ever have on reality why is that
um I think I got what I needed to out of
it you know
the mutation you are the most beautiful
girl here in paradise I therefore crown
you the Queen yeah absolutely
so I never would have thought I ever
would have done an experience like this
it this was never a goal of mine but you
know one of the show to potentially find
a you know a love interest and I got
just that so you're like an iceberg JPJ
there's like stuff on the surface but
there's so much more below you know oh
I'm flattered thank you
what do you love so much about her um
she's just a really good person and you
know she's cause she constantly strives
to better herself and the people around
her and you know she has very ambitious
goals and you know I'm attracted to that
ah we'll see we're working on it and you
removed yourself from the group text the
bachelor in paradise group text why was
that is everybody on there yes so all
the contestants were on there and you
know I was struggling with the break-up
at the time and Taoiseach was in that
group text and you know I the best way
that in my mind who gotten over her was
to just remove her you know from my life
and I just didn't need to you know think
about her and I just think that would
have helped with the healing process did
you and Derek ever go off on each other
in the group text no I didn't have any
participation in the group text your
friend Peters The Bachelor
my god what was your thought on it it's
so cool I remember sitting with Peter
Peter sat right next to me in the limo
of night one so it's totally crazy he's
a great guy
I think he's really in a spot personally
professionally to settle down and I
think we'll have a great time watching
him find his love interest a lot of
people cheering for Mike and he was on
your season too do you think Peter's the
right choice I don't think one is like
necessarily better than the other but I
think Peters an outstanding candidate
we're gonna back you up in time to the
break-up with tisha
so you and tisha you ended things
she ended things with me
want to get there
how hard was that for you in that moment
yeah it was very difficult in that
moment and it made me question
everything I was very skeptical of going
to paradise to begin with and I just
didn't have a great experience
romantically on The Bachelorette so I
really it really just kind of questioned
the authenticity of everything sometimes
I didn't know if you really thought
you're on TV John Pilger that's funny I
don't know you didn't know to not eat
the date food how do you do you know do
you know something I don't know I'm just
saying you're not why I've very I've
very like limited amount of knowledge on
the whole Bachelor franchise and I
didn't really you know I didn't really
do any research on it because I think it
I think it was just beneficial to not
know anything about it so I think the
fans kind of liked my sort of
obliviousness to The Bachelor food
[Music]
[Applause]